you're watching Al Jazeera live from our
headquarters in delha I'm the arena also
coming up fighting intensifies in the
Sudanese city of umdarman at least 18
people have been killed in the latest
violence in the region
Ukrainian forces say they've retaken a
fourth Village in the Eastern Donuts
region in their counter-offensive
against Russia and the four children who
survived 40 days in the Amazon jungle
after their plane crashed speak about
their harrowing ordeal
[Music]
hello we begin with breaking news from
Italy and the former prime minister
Sylvia Berlusconi has died at the age of
86. he had served multiple terms as
leader he was admitted to a hospital in
Milan on Friday for what AIDS said were
pre-planned tests related to his
leukemia well the billionaire
businessman created Italy's largest
Media company and also owned the leading
football club AC Milan burlosconi faced
multiple legal and sex scandals
eventually leading to his resignation we
have Al jazeera's who is joining us on
the phone from Sardinia so tell us what
we know up until this point
well we all all we know from is what the
hospital in Milan said the San Rafael
hospital that he actually had a quiet
night but then this morning things went
very quickly his close relatives his
children his brother uh were all called
in uh and then shortly after the San
Rafael indeed uh issued a statement
saying that filiberlusconi had died
after battling this a form of leukemia
that had seen him spend about six weeks
in hospital earlier this year
excuse me he's described as as
transforming the political landscape in
Italy how will he be remembered
I think he would be remembered with
mixed feelings by some people because he
was also plagued with scandals of sexual
nature he was also plagued with
corruption scandals uh but he was a man
who was referred to by the Italians in
general by the media as in cavaliere
which is not a title he earned in any
shape or form except that it he was
considered really a king maker in
politics and actually just as we speak
now I mean his body for say Italian the
right Coalition is still in power under
the Premiership of Georgia Maloney so he
is so certainly someone who has had a
huge impact on Italian politics uh in
recent memory he was the long longest
serving prime minister but he also had
an impact on Italians I would say on a
daily basis because he also transformed
the television landscape with his big
group called media set so certainly a
man who has or many people in Italy say
most impacted rightly or wrongly Italian
way of life and Italian politics over
the past three decades yeah and as
you're saying not only a politician but
also a media Mogul as well talk to us
about the impact he had on the media
landscape a little bit more and also
perhaps the economic impact he had on
the country
well I would say that I mean up until he
came up with his group of media set
which includes three major channels uh
that are widely followed by everyone in
Italy the landscape uh the media
landscape in Italy was really in the
hands of the Rye which is the government
uh media that all changed when silver
bellusconi came commercial it led to the
rise of commercial TV he also owns
several print Publications so certainly
what he did was a big earthquake I would
say in the media landscape and as you
mentioned before he was also uh owner of
the AC Milan at some point uh he had a
huge business uh going on in several uh
side in several Fields I would say but
it's really the media one that kept him
afloat and also uh really LED also to
this extravagant lifestyle that he had
these big parties that were scandalous
uh that had huge repercussions on his
political career
okay thank you so much for that update
from Italy on the death of Silvio
Berlusconi we have a report Now by
Nadeem Baba who has more on Berlusconi
Silvio Berlusconi was never happier than
when performing in front of his
supporters at home or on the global
stage
his playful touch was loved by Sun but
loathed by others
he was prime minister four times and was
Italy's longest-serving post-war leader
this one-time cruise ship crooner turned
property Tycoon went on to own Italy's
biggest media Empire and be chairman of
his beloved football team AC Milan he
wielded tremendous influence
with an estimated Fortune of 9 billion
dollars belusconi persuaded many
Italians he was the right man to lead
them but controversy followed him
notoriety he sometimes seemed to relish
I am the most legally persecuted Man Of
All Times in the whole history of
mankind worldwide because I have been
subjected to more than 2 500 Court
hearings
his charm worked sometimes even when he
kept important friends waiting
but his attempts at humor often
backfired
I have to bring you some greetings
greetings from a man what's his name
just a minute it was someone with a tan
Barack Obama
then there was the personal vanity the
facelifts the permanent tan all the
better for selling Italy's image abroad
or so he claimed Berlusconi rolled with
the political punches as well as the
literal ones
assaulted during a campaign rally in
Milan
as the Litany of legal battles against
him became more urid Italian patients
wore thin he was convicted of tax fraud
in 2013 and later of political
corruption
he narrowly avoided jail but the
convictions barred him from office until
2019 and then there were the accusations
of organizing sex parties attended by
underage prostitutes his political and
personal dramas inspired a Blockbuster
movie
economy that would eventually seal his
political fate Italy's burden of debt
took it to the brink of bankruptcy and
Berlusconi into confrontation with
European partners
in recent years he faded from Frontline
politics dogged by health concerns
he recaused himself as a nature lover
and a family man but he became a senator
in 2022 and as leader of Forza Italia
the political party he founded he was
never too far from the Reigns of power
Let's uh speak to Alan Friedman who's an
Italian political commentator and he
wrote the biography my way Berlusconi in
his own words you're joining us from
Lugano thank you so much for your time
with us on Al Jazeera so what's your
reaction to this news that Berlusconi
has died
well his health was deteriorating in
recent years
but of course this is a very very
historic figure in post-war Italian
History sir Silvio Berlusconi was a
controversial figure he was a four-time
prime minister
he was tried on various corruption and
bribery scandals and tax frauds candles
more than 70 times
he was in many ways the original
populist in Italy back in the 90s
and although he was controversial he was
also much loved by his followers yeah
he's also been described as really
transforming the political landscape in
Italy how do you think he's going to be
remembered
I think Berlusconi will be remembered as
a billionaire uh media Mogul who built a
big commercial television system and in
Italy in the 80s and then in the early
1990s he'll be remembered as the man who
when scandals caused the collapse of the
Italian post-war political party system
Berlusconi formed a party called forts
Italia he launched it with Madison
Avenue advertising tactics using his own
company to get elected uh his own
television and he will be considered a
controversial figure who never really
accomplished anything substantial on the
economic policy front or in doing great
reforms for Italy and seemed mostly
interested in protecting himself from
legal problems so he'll be considered a
a brilliant but flawed figure in history
talk about the controversies obviously
there were many as you were saying but
at the same time you say that he he was
loved how do you explain that
well um Berlusconi uh to his credit was
what the Italians like to call simpatico
he had charm he had Charisma uh and he
loved to tell anecdotes and stories as
his biography as his biographer I had to
listen to the same stories many times
over when I was uh virtually living with
him in 2014-15 writing the biography and
making a documentary uh he was also a
very egotistical man in the documentary
uh my way which was based on the book
which ran for five years on Netflix and
uh which I now have the rights to in
that documentary uh Berlusconi takes me
on a tour of his house his Mansion his
pictures of himself as Superman his
swimming pool
his family church his football field he
was a very grandiose billionaire figure
as well so on the one hand he had charm
on on the other hand he was accused of
breaking the law and ultimately was
convicted for criminal tax fraud and had
to serve a year of community service
okay uh thank you so much for sharing
your thoughts with us uh Alan Friedman
we appreciate your time uh Alan Friedman
speaking to us from Lugano and just uh
to bring you right up to speed with what
we know so far is that the former
Italian Prime Minister Sylvia bolusconi
has died at the age of 86. he had served
multiple terms as leader and what we
know is that he was admitted to hospital
in Milan on Friday for what AIDS we're
describing as pre-planned tests related
to his leukemia but we now know that he
has died
that happened a little earlier on today